endlich wieder entlockt unsere new
york-reise 2022
[Musik]
gekauft und hätte die 15-Jährige Kiki
damals gedacht dass irgendwann wirklich
ins Central Park sitzt und hier ein
Bagel probiert hat gesagt never ever ich
bin gespannt es ist schon viel muss ich
sagen es ist schon extrem Portion
[Musik]
gut aber nicht frisch
obwohl sie immer wieder frische Berge
zugetan haben
mir so fluffy sind die gar nicht die
schmecken so als wären die also als wenn
jetzt der Bagel sag mal morgens um 6 Uhr
fertig gebacken war und ich habe ihn
irgendwie sechs Stunden später gekauft
so schmeckt er nicht schlecht aber auch
nicht mega frisch und die also diese
Frischkäse innen drin mit dem
Lauchzwiebeln schmeckt einfach genauso
wie wenn man das von Griechen oder so
oder vom Türken kauft so Antipasti sag
mal gar nicht also abschließend muss ich
sagen geht auf jeden Fall klar zum
Frühstück
Käse genau
ich habe jetzt hier einmal mit Zwiebeln
genommen und ähm hier ist noch einer mit
Knoblauch da gab es noch verschiedene
sesamen Kümmel etc und dann kann man
sich einfach verschiedene
frischkäsesorten auswählen und belegen
lassen ich muss sagen es ist okay aber
es haut mich jetzt nicht unbedingt
ich weiß es nicht
weniger ist mehr finde ich auch immer
also
der ist doch richtig hier ne
Frage
fluffy sein weißt du und die Füllung ist
halt ja tomatenlastig
aber ist zu viel einfacher also ich bin
gerade bisschen enttäuscht weil ich
wollte eigentlich schwanger glaube ich
was essen
hart hartes Brötchen bekommen gefühlt
keinen Spaß ja ganz ehrlich aber ich
finde dass die Tomaten also dieser
Tomaten Frischkäse schmeckt echt ganz
okay ein bisschen zu sauer aber sonst
ganz okay aber das ist
Rotlicht ja aber das Brot ist einfach
viel zu dick und dadurch ist er nicht so
geil
wie man
sieht also drauf drückt man könnte
meinen dass das fluffy
[Musik]
probiere jetzt diesen XXL coffeebahn ich
weiß nicht was es ist ich habe das
Gefühl dass es einfach so ein richtig
softer aber so leicht klebriger Teig
ohne Füllung gucken ob eine Füllung drin
ist
keine Füllung ist aber auch gar nicht
schlimm weil das so richtig fluffig
aussieht
oder riecht extrem nach Kaffee
geiler Nachgeschmack man beißt rein
schmeckt relativ neutral danach kommt
der Bus Riegel Geschmack und ganz am
Ende kommt der Kaffeegeschmack schon
geil aber ich finde dass man zum
kaffeeband noch einen heißen Kaffee
braucht aber irgendwie geil
erst Enttäuschung und dann pures Glück
irgendwie
schmeckt gut aber ist halt nichts wo es
sich umhaut aber dann kriegst du doch
diese Kaffeegeschmack und schmeckt
irgendwie geil ja
vermisst habe das ist einfach dieses
weiche das muss ich genauso sein
deswegen
50% so fluffig wie das Baby perfekt
gewesen
ne kann das sein der sitzt oben ja der
ist gar nicht
im baden können
Kaffee Granulat vom Backen also ganz
ganz
krass voll die Enttäuschung hey warte
mal ich muss mal kurz auf mein Leben
klarkommen ja man erwartet so das quillt
raus und so guck mal das ist einfach
eine Höhle und das sieht auch so
herzhaft aus
voll fähig ich bin gespannt das sieht
irgendwie so herzhaft aus deswegen hat
mich so an diese Füllung von Porsche
also ich schmecke rein nur die die feste
Außenhülle und den Zucker aber ich
schmecke nichts vom cream schießen gar
nicht es schmeckt wirklich
eher ich will eher Nachos
finden vom Namen her
gar nicht
drin ist
aber nur im Abgang
also müsste rausquillen würde ich das
würde ich feiern aber trotzdem okay
amerikanisch normalerweise
hier muss alles rausquillen guck mal ich
weiß jetzt genau da rein wo du rein
Gewissen hast
[Musik]
also dieser b-vlog der sitzt du mir noch
so tief in den Knochen dass ich gesagt
habe ich muss in New York einen guten
Bagel zum Frühstück essen und dann war
ich jetzt hier bei ihnen kommen und ich
sage euch das war eine glatte 10 von 10
ich habe nichts zu bemängelt der Teig
war außen leicht groß in den super
fluffig und hat total frisch geschmeckt
und einfach echt gut und der Kaffee war
auch mega der Kaffee bekommt man auch
volle Punktzahl und dann haben wir noch
dieses Mandel Croissant gesehen
selbstgebauten gönnen wir uns wir sind
noch einmal in New York
der ist doch gefüllt ich habe gedacht
der ist nicht gefüllt
die Mandel beziehen sich nur auf oben
drüber aber
mega
schmeckt wie ganz frisch aus dem Ofen
und komplett selbst gebacken also mein
Schatz
das ist ein fettes Ding also Amerika ist
alles
Tomatensoße zu Tomate also da waren kaum
Gewürze dabei also ich meine das
übertrieben
auf jeden Fall flüssiger
[Musik]
ist immer dabei Eigenproduktion
wie macht man immer selbst drauf also
was haben wir uns jetzt bestellt von den
Harald geil genau einfach so ein
Schinkenplatte wir teilen uns jetzt und
da gibt's auch Gyros da gibt es Falafel
und Hummus also so viel gibt's da gar
nicht an Auswahl
[Musik]
so mitten in New York irgendwas der Bank
sitzen und Harald Eis essen richtig geil
ich bin mal gespannt wie es schmeckt
also auf Instagram hat eine Person
geschrieben es ist komplett überbewertet
ich habe gar nichts gefragt ne das also
der ist einfach bekannt dieser Truck
also Halla guys ist eigentlich eher so
ein food Truck gibt's an mehreren Orten
und es ist eigentlich total Gehalt also
sie haben ganz wenig auf der Speisekarte
und äh ist aber immer eine Schlange okay
jetzt hatten wir Glück ich glaube jetzt
wegen der Uhrzeit aber
noch haben
boah ich kann ihn halt verstehen
[Musik]
Zwiebeln richtig lecker
und das Hähnchen ist so es ist wie Pult
es ist aber nicht gut aber es schmeckt
wie so zerrupft es schmeckt total zart
kommt der eingeschmack vom vom Hähnchen
raus aber so ein paar Gewürze sind dabei
nicht zu viel einfach nicht zu nicht zu
übertönt nicht und hier unten ist auch
noch Reis der ist auch mega Gewürz
dieser Orangen Reis und das Brot ist
oder
jetzt bin ich gespannt
das Hähnchen du weißt es einfach nur
Hähnchen ist ein bisschen Gewürze drauf
das war's simpel und lecker lecker
[Musik]
richtig gut
also ich kann das voll verstehen
vielfältig aber ich finde New York ist
so viel Burger lass dich Pizza und
schnelle Gerichte und sowas ne und da
hast du irgendwie das Gefühl dass du
Hausmann kostet also ich feiere das
richtig denken
[Musik]
überrascht wir sind in der Milchbar wir
sind jetzt mal U-Bahn gefahren nicht so
hell wohin geht's und dann hat er gesagt
das ist ein Lokal von einer
foodbloggerin Christina thossi ich habe
hier Netflix Serie vor ein paar Jahren
gemacht zusammengeschaut und ich feier
das einfach dass sie sich selbstständig
gemacht haben und bekannt dass die Dame
für ihren Geburtstagskuchen und
eigentlich stehe ich gar nicht auf so
nur Teig und dann ist es wahrscheinlich
Buttercreme oder so aber sie ist halt
bekannt dafür
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also wie der San Sebastian Cheesecake
bei mir im Café ist das quasi von
Christina das Steckenpferd ich bin so
gespannt wenn man so die Netflix Serie
verfolgt hat also es fühlt sich hier
beim Abmachen unser trocken an oh Gott
es fällt schon ein bisschen auseinander
typisch amerikanische süß es ist schon
ein bisschen trocken was ich richtig
geil finde den dazwischen diese
crispy Teile das ist total also es sieht
so aus wie ein gefärbtes aber es ist
einfach irgendwas
sagen
noch nie wirklich so mega krank
[Musik]
unserem Abgang und das feier ich
irgendwie
[Musik]
also ich finde man schmeckt auch ein
bisschen zuckerriss darüber er ist schon
sehr süß das ist der typisch typische
Bettdecke ohne Spaß genauso schmeckt
auch aber ich finde es auch interessant
das schmeckt so ein bisschen
schmeckt auch so ein bisschen so
fruchtig auch ne aber an sich muss ich
sagen jetzt es ist schwierig ne das ist
selber ein Kaffee das ganze bastian ist
da du feierst den voll und da komme ich
jetzt sage ich fahre ich bin ja nicht so
lecker also ich finde es gut aber nicht
jetzt mega geil ganz ehrlich an
es ist zwar ein bisschen trockene der
Boden aber der ist trotzdem feucht ja
das ist eine Hoffnung
aber meistens diese Abgänge
das ist schon sehr süß aber das wollte
ich ja auch noch mal betonen
weil es ist also der Boden bröselt mega
man hat das Gefühl du wolltest dann weiß
man aber durch durch den Speichel im
Gaumen fühlt sich alles wieder zusammen
das schmeckt auf einmal wieder feucht
also Magic so ein Stück reicht auch ne
ja wir sind hier preislich hierbei
das Stück hat 11 Dollar gekostet und man
kann es sich zu zweit teilen also muss
man mit 5 Dollar 50 pro Person
eingestellt werden
manchmal mit meinem kleinen Hunger kann
man sich dann auch die zweiteilen und
wenn man den einfach feiert so wie ich
dann wird man sich jeden aber es ist ein
new yorkerverhältnisse es ist halt immer
etwas
wahrscheinlich schon 30 000 Monaten
ganz normales ist es so diese
einwegbestecke auch dass die obwohl wir
hier essen
Grinch also ich schade
Verpackungsmüll also das ist heavy das
auch echt wie so ein geiles Gefühl
unsere Schwester
das einfach ein neues Produkt gemacht
nämlich Pralinen und auch verkaufen
einfach ein bisschen mehr produziert
dafür dass man machen kann
[Musik]
eigentlich sehr unscheinbar wie alles
hier irgendwie was gut ist es ist
koreanisch angehauchtes Frühstück es
gibt aber auch Mittagessen aber es ist
eher so ein frühstücksladen und ich muss
sagen ich hatte was veganes also ich
hatte Tofu in so einem Sandwich und dann
haben wir uns erst über den Preis
gewundert also 15 $ für so ein Sandwich
schon echt viel und dann gab es aber in
so einer Box noch ein veganen Muffin
dazu und noch eine Soße und Früchte etc
war schon echt lecker muss ich sagen
also man fühlt sich auch nicht so super
schlecht denn man hat gemerkt dass man
einfach frische Zutaten es gibt auch
nicht vegane Sachen die haben Fisch
richtig gefallen
wir fahren hier auch keine Erdbeersaison
ja aber dann auch die Mitarbeiter
ultranet wir hatten also ich hatte einen
Spirulina Latte was ich komisch fand war
die Präsentation dass das dass er also
der Kellner auch sagte auf dem Deckel
gibt es ein Loch und da kann man raus
trinken und das ist einfach so schön zu
präsentieren warum hat man nicht einfach
den Deckel komplett weggelassen ja
auf dem Foto auf dem Foto sieht echt
mehr
schmeckt irgendwie wieder
Latte ich finde der hat schon nach ähm
das milchiges geschmeckt das hat aber so
ein grasigen Nachgeschmack so wie ein
abgeschwächte Version von Matcha also
gleich
Jake wartet auf mich auf jeden Fall und
mein Kaffee war richtig richtig stark
empfehlen
die Küche ist gekommen und eigentlich
alle gefragt ob es schmeckt und so
weiter hat sich kurz unterhalten echt
das macht das macht es aus finde ich
dieses Mädchen
[Musik]
das sind mal dicke Ossis lewand Bakery
sind so wie viral gegangen diese Cookies
die Leute standen richtig Schlange ist
ein richtig fest muss ich sagen
heftig und der Geruch ist einfach
absolut krank
wird mir jetzt nicht wünschen
kein gutes Zeichen ich muss sagen Essen
leckere Cookies aber die schmecken so
ein bisschen wie gekauft also die
schmecken nicht selbst gebacken ich
glaube es liegt einfach davon dass es so
extrem XXL ist aber ich bin leicht
enttäuscht ich muss leider echt ehrlich
sein auch wenn ich vielleicht
unsympathisch rüberkommen
aber Schokobrötchen sind richtig Saft
Schokobrötchen so in die Richtung
schmeckt
sind das ist nicht typisch Cookies
[Musik]